so we're seeing increased concern uh not
yet panic but concern for now about the
spread of monkey pox possibly through
sexual contact which we're going to talk
about uh sort of as the second part of
this story so first of all what is
monkey pox monkey pox is an infectious
disease a communicable disease that can
be transmitted between animals and
people and also between people is caused
by the monkey pox virus the symptoms are
initially fever headache muscle pain
swollen lymph nodes and feeling tired
and then later you get this rash that
forms blisters which crust over and in
that sense it's in the kind of Universe
of smallpox chickenpox
Etc the type from when you're exp the
time from when you're exposed until you
get symptoms is typically around 10 days
which as you can imagine
can make contact tracing potentially
more difficult and the duration of
symptoms is typically two to four weeks
it can look a lot like chickenpox in
humans and the ways that it spreads
unlike covid it does not uh tend to
spread through aerosolized virus
particles although it's conceivable that
if you have respiratory involvement it
could spread in that way but primarily
monkey pox spreads through the handling
of what's called bush meat uh through
being bit by an animal or scratched by
an animal carrying it and then between
humans it can spread through bodily
fluids contaminated objects close
contact with other humans who have it
the smallpox vaccine
not the monkey pox vaccine the smallpox
vaccine is believed to be about 85
percent effective at preventing monkey
pox and then in 2019 a monkey pox
vaccine called and I hope I'm
pronouncing this correctly janeos also
known as mvanex in the European Union
and in the moon in Canada was approved
for adults in the United States so
that's monkey pox what's happening in
this particular outbreak earlier this
month several cases were identified in
London and one in Northeast England
Portugal and Spain have reported several
cases and then a case was confirmed in
Massachusetts by the CDC after a man
traveled to Canada
potentially uh there's a case in New
York City that's under investigation and
health officials are investigating what
is believed to be Florida's first
positive case it's a presumptive
positive case uh in South Florida that
case appears to be related to
international travel and that person is
isolated
um the Canadian Nexus is that earlier
this month in Quebec two cases were
confirmed 20 more are still under
investigation in Canada so how is it
spreading uh what's the connection here
the who right now is working on a sexual
contact Theory this is very early we
don't have all the details but David
Hayman from the who spoke to Reuters and
is working on the idea that there seems
to be a possible sexual contact kind of
chain in a number of the cases so far
Heyman said quote what seems to be
happening now is that it's got into the
population as a sexual form a genital
form and is being spread as a sexually
transmitted infection
which has Amplified its transmission
around the world very early
important things and if you're wondering
oh no are there already conspiracy
theories about monkeypox yes there are
and we're going to get to the
momentarily but if you're wondering
number one is this likely to trigger a
global covid type response the answer is
almost certainly not this spreads
differently it's less contagious and
we're going to deal with that kind of in
the conspiracy segment and number two is
this strictly speaking a sexually
transmitted disease strictly speaking
it's not but it is a disease that can be
spread through sexual contact uh and
we're going to have more information
about that as we continue to learn about
this but that's the latest from uh The
Who and other Authorities on monkey pox
yes let's talk about the conspiracy
theories
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for Quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release is
no exception it's the Argo automatic it
spotlights everything I love about
vincero I got the Argo automatic in
Frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but I really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out I love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face I really
love all of their watches and I own a
bunch but the Argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero Collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below